[Music]
welcome back Hannity now earlier today I
interviewed President Trump at the 193rd
special operations wing at the Air
National Guard base in Middletown
Pennsylvania
now here's part two of that exclusive
interview take a look a lot of people I
was surprised watching all last year
with Colin Kaepernick I praised a
murdering thug
dictator he had socks that depicted cops
his pigs and and other issues he
actually donated to a charity that
actually supported a cop killer and then
we saw the NFL and you took it on it
appears based on the letter that Roger
Goodell put out yesterday that Donald
Trump initiated a debate over standing
for the flag and our anthem and those
that fought bled and died and looks like
you won
so let's spelling peppermint and I
thought it was terrible and then it got
bigger and bigger and started
mushrooming and frankly the NFL should
have suspended him for one game and he
would have never done it again they
could have been suspended for two games
and they could have suspended him if he
did it a third time for the season and
you would never have had a problem but I
will tell you you cannot disrespect our
country or flag our anthem you cannot do
that obviously the people of a country
of with you hundreds of thousands of
people fought bled hundreds of thousands
died fighting under that flag right when
you look at the Obama years Chicago one
city his adopted hometown 3,900 people
were murdered in the last six years of
Obama's presidency 18,000 shootings I
don't think he mentioned it but three or
four times yeah it's hard to and
disproportionately his economic policies
hurt black Americans Hispanic Americans
more as Maurice how will your policies
help minorities that are still struggle
well first of all minorities want police
protection
more than anybody they need it more than
anybody it's what's going on is crazy
and you look at some of these inner
cities where it's just out of control
and remember I was saying things like we
will you know what do you have to lose
we will fix it we're gonna fix it but
one of the things we're doing very
strongly now is the inner cities now
Chicago is out of control I don't know
what they're doing in Chicago to have
this many shootings and this many
killings and all of the different things
that are going on this is not like it's
the United States of America and pure
and simple that's bad management
that's bad politics it's incredible and
then you talk to them why aren't you
doing something we want to talk to you
about it it's it's really insulting to
our nation and whether you take on the
NFL or you take on Chicago and some of
our other cities this shouldn't be
murders like this and you know we have
incredible police in this country they
could stop it if they were
thank you John
in many cases it's the police are not
allowed to do their job they have to be
politically correct we're talking about
lives of wonderful people and they have
to be allowed to do their job and you
will see it's tough I'll never forget I
was in Chicago and a police officer said
there was a motorcycle deal to the plane
and I was talking to the police I was
taking a picture I said how do you stop
this we could stop it immediately sir
and so what he means you can stop them
if they'd let us do our job we could
stop it immediately now at some point
you're gonna have to let them do their
job and they want to do their job that's
the incredible thing we did it on the
border the border was like a sieve now
it's down 78% that's without the wall
where do you see what happens where we
go the wall but but general Kelly has
done an incredible job these are people
they know how to do it but they have to
be allowed to do it look at the
difference in the borders all Rudy
Guiliani New York Rudy did a fantastic
job in New York and that's an example
and Rudy was so another campaign and
when Rudy endorsed me to me that was a
very important endorsement because he
did a great job especially with respect
well you could also say economic
development but especially with respect
to crime in New York City we watched a
lot of high-profile incidents during the
Obama years Ferguson
Trayvon Martin in Florida Freddie gray
he called the because he said the
Cambridge Police Act that stupidly it
seems every two or four years that I've
been now thirty years in radio I just
started my 23rd year of Fox that every
two or four years
thank you every two to four years the
Democrats will play the race card and I
resent it as a conservative because
they'll say all their policies they're
racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic and meanwhile their
policies haven't helped the minority
communities in America is there a way
from the federal government's
perspective that you can bring Economic
Opportunity and Safety and that's what
we have said you look at what's happened
in our inner cities there it's a it's
horrible what's going on in terms of the
death in terms of shooting a woman gets
up and she wants to go on walking with
her beautiful daughter get a loaf of
bread and she ends up getting shot or
the daughter gets shot and we can stop
it don't forget the Democrats have ruled
the inner cities for a hundred years
this is their rule very rarely do you
have a Republican there but this is
their rule that can be turned around we
can do so many things but the Democrats
have truly ruled and and when I was
running I would always say what do you
have to lose I remember if this came up
out of nowhere I'm reading the
statistics of a certain inner city which
were terrible education is terrible
crime rate is terrible every single
element economic development jobs or
everybody was unemployed and I said just
I really never sing and I look at the
audience they say what the hell do you
have to lose the place went crazy and
then I'd actually use it again and again
and we went up and we're doing a good
job Ben Carson's doing a great job at
HUD he's got great heart
the Democrats rule the inner cities and
when I say what do you have to lose it's
so bad that really the Republicans
should be starting to do very well but
we're doing a good job and we're
stopping a lot of the crime
[Music]